what's up
guys bang bang it is lunch
money time well while she's trying to
get rich for us that's just trying to
get our lunch money right i'm here with
the beautiful intelligent planet evilova
marinovo
commented on these tigers because if you
ignore
it it ain't real blockfi
is now the sponsor of lunch money
go and get a blackfy account blockfy.com
you can earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest-bearing account you
can sign up for the waitlist for their
bitcoin rewards credit card
go get an account blockfy.com slash pomp
all right nice what's going on well
first i have an announcement
go to my youtube page i i don't know
what is it i think if you just search my
name paulina marinova popliano it'll
come up
but or go to theprofile.sac.com
for a great interview with noah galloway
come on that's all all right let's start
oh god
hold on a second she's not ready see
she's not ready that's fine
i'll actually cover for her at the
moment and just say that restaurants
oh go ahead i was just gonna say the
conversation with noah galway is really
cool he was in iraq
uh he got his left arm and left leg
blown off
he came back he ended up being on the uh
wasn't dancing with the stars
he was on the cover of men's fitness
dude is a
savage and uh he just gets it so go
listen
it's great conversation cool thank you
that buy you enough time thank you yes
so 10 000 restaurants are slated
to close in the next few weeks
due to the pandemic why the next three
weeks that's just the
um about 17 of america's restaurants
have already permanently closed this
year with thousands more on the brink
according to the national restaurant
association
and uh the nra the national restaurant
association
is publicly pleading with congress to
pass new stimulus to help the industry
that's been damaged but i i honestly to
be totally honest have no idea how these
restaurants have continued
on how have the ones who have survived
survived where is the money coming from
well they might have access to capital
they may have i don't know run a good
business and save money over time i
think it's a really
thin margin business of course all
that's all that is true of course
but you know what fixes the problem for
restaurants open them up
have the businesses open they won't do
that i know because
you know it's science that if you sit
outside that you'll
increase the likelihood that you get the
virus come on at the end of the day
what fixes the economic problems is open
the economy
protect the people who are most
vulnerable the older you
are the pre-existing conditions or if
you're just scared
sit inside we'll help you get those
people aid
and open up the economy and get back to
life let's go
all right next spacex is getting 885
million dollars i believe from the fcc
uh so that its starlink satellite
service could be a game changer
for places where lane fiber isn't an
option so providing um
wi-fi and i should do i should write up
a whole piece about this so
when i was at facebook we started
something called internet.org
i say we i literally uh
joined that team for two days and
they're like all right we're gonna like
disband this part of the team and i was
like okay so i gotta go do something
else
um but uh they have internet.org
google had their project loon um you
know there's a bunch of these things so
it's like can we fly
um uh hot air balloons and beam the
internet down
can we do it via drones lasers all kinds
of crazy ideas
uh spacex seems to be the one who has
made the most progress with
starlink and if they end up making they
use satellites right yeah they put
satellites in
um kind of you know orbiting around the
earth if they make this work
this could be one of the most valuable
companies in the world as a
starlink will spin out of spacex so
it's going to be pretty crazy to watch
this all play out but uh i think this is
going to end up being a pretty special
company
that's really cool worth watching okay
peloton
shares are falling as apple announces a
cheaper
rival fitness service that launches
december 14th
it's called fitness plus a digital
fitness subscription service
at 99 999 a month
and it wants to compete yeah
yeah but i think that peloton
uh peloton's nps i saw people tweeting
about this yesterday is like 94.
yeah which is crazy which is like a
religion yeah
it's literally equivalent to the nps of
a religion and
also i get what apple's trying to do but
like apple doesn't have
a bike so it's gonna rely on your apple
watch which
i feel like you can kind of already do
like you can sync your watch to things
i i don't see the innovation sorry i
think that apple will
turn this into a profitable business but
i don't think that it will have the
impact on peloton that everyone thinks
you don't think so it's are you sure yes
okay but it's cheaper it's 9.99 compared
to 12.99
how much does netflix cost most of the
people watching this don't know
i think it increased to like yeah it did
increase
i don't know how much it is whether it
was 9.99 12.99 or 15.99 i would still
pay with your finances but you would
no it's because i i'm price
uh elastic right meaning that
it does if they made it 19.99 it's
something that i value that i use all
the time so i'd be willing to i would
think about netflix
if it was 19.99 a month you would get
rid of your netflix
i didn't think so okay next
um okay well what are we on
oh my god guys linda is very disjointed
today
fellas and ladies uber is selling its
self-driving car business to
aurora i have a really hard time saying
that word
okay aurora oh my god if there weren't a
million ads on this site
so aurora is a five year hold on
it developed self-driving vehicles but
it was marred by litigation and a fatal
crash but aurora
is pretty well known um yeah uber will
take a 26
stake in aurora and invest 400 million
in the startup
um amazon's one investor
what do you have to say about this i
mean look it we know that the
automated taxis are coming like this
idea that you won't own the car
you'll simply there will literally just
be automated cars driving around your
city
and you'll just call one and you'll jump
in and it'll go like it's like the
jetsons basically
like that is going to happen it's just a
matter of when it happens
and who's going to be the players that
make it occur but we need to get
self-driving car technology especially
in urban areas
uh drastically increased and uh
efficiently so i remember being at a
fortune conference called brainstorm
tech
a few years ago and dara who's the
current ceo of
uber was there and he was talking about
how that
is the future of uber and apparently
uber used to believe that developing
self-driving cars was essential for it
to survive given that self-driving cars
might make human-driven vehicles
expensive and irrelevant
and here's what uber founder travis
kanek said in a 2014 interview
if uber doesn't go there it's not going
to exist either way that's just the way
of the world
that's the way of technology and
progress unfortunately we all have to
find ways to change with the world
so if it doesn't get there do you think
uber will be extinct
no uber's not going anywhere why though
just adapt to them
yeah self-driving no uber is the
category defining company they're not
going anywhere
okay that's how technology works
howard stern has extended how much are
you getting paid
so the terms of the deal were not
disclosed but it's rumored 100 million
per year
my guy howard stern's been talking about
sex
for two decades and he's gotten billions
of dollars he's extending his
long-running sirius xm radio deal for
five
more years that's another 500 million if
that's true
yeah he supposedly he's been getting
paid between 80
and 100 million dollars a year since
like the beginning of the 2000s since
the beginning of time
i mean this guy's been getting paid an
ungodly amount of money
forever he said 15 years ago i joined
sirius xm a fledgling group of
broadcasters i had been in a toxic
relationship with terrestrial radio
and no matter how well i treated the
medium no matter how successful i made
them they abused me
going to sirius xm liberated me so 15
years ago sirius xm was like the hot new
thing right
yeah he he came over there i've seen
estimations that like
20 to 30 percent of serious subscribers
would leave if howard stern left
what where would they go i mean
obviously
these are people who are like making you
know pretty absurd things uh because
they also get pre-installed on cars and
all that kind of stuff but
it is very clear that howard stern has
had a massive impact on that business
that's why they're paying them a hundred
million dollars a year but but can
can we just talk about for one second
the influence that um
someone like that can make for a company
like sirius
right so i mean joe rogan moving the
spotify like i think these
big names it's kind of a stamp of
approval like i
this is gonna be around for a long time
and i'm willing to make a bet on
something smaller
and yeah but like spotify is like a you
know multi-billion dollars no i know
i know but it wasn't it's still kind of
like the
what i want to know is that howard stern
gets stock at any point did he get stock
or
are they just paying him in cash who
knows sure all right let's ask lunch
money time
guys use hashtag ask lm in the comments
what's the first question
john i'd love to hear how you guys feel
about 401ks and if you use them i'm 27
and the plan is to retire early
i live below my means and invest
everything else good for you john
i don't like the idea of the far 401k
funds
not being available until my 60s oh
yeah so i have i have it for a walk
but also my role in
with money is very very very very
conservative whereas his is
the opposite of that basically we're
going all on black let's see what
happens now
um the way that i think about all
retirement plans
is i actually think of them as tax plans
so
uh your 401k really just serves as a way
to
decrease your income uh your taxable
income and so you should max it out
uh at all times uh in my opinion uh
on top of that it's uh depending on the
plan that you're
looking at if it's something that has
your employer uh participating
there is usually free money involved so
they may match they may do all that kind
of stuff
and so the way that i normally think
about these things is
if you want there is a high degree
of advantage in terms of
getting income into a retirement
all around a um kind of tax deferral
type
model or tax-free model and then what
happens is the beauty of it once it's in
the tax account
uh or i'm sorry the retirement account
is that you don't
get taxed as it grows and so there's a
huge advantage if you can compound money
without it being taxed
um obviously that can be uh attractive
as well
so rendra but you can't get it until
you're 60 or you know 62 or whatever it
is
um but you know the way that i kind of
think about that is like
you don't need the money it's a
percentage it's a percentage of your
portfolio
surrender asks pomp what do you think is
gonna happen with the giant banks like
jp morgan goldman and all the banks in
general against bitcoin and crypto world
like how do you think that's going to
play out especially if banks start using
blockchain
yeah they're just going to try to adopt
this stuff like it it is now a race it
is a global race to see
if you're a central bank which central
banks adopt at first if you're a
traditional bank who's the first to
adopt it if you're just an
average joe who's the first to adopt it
like there is a global race underway
uh and the banks are not going to sit by
and just let this happen
um there will be some that fight it and
end up getting disrupted
uh but there will be some that embrace
it and end up being you know kind of
gaining the advantage of it but i i tend
to think that
uh this idea that like oh crypto's just
gonna happen and the banks are gonna
be like i didn't see that coming uh is
very unlikely
and it's really funny because we know a
lot of people who work at traditional
banks
who are very long bitcoin yeah of course
well uh bitcoin and everything else like
they're they're all paying attention
literally
there's people who work at some of the
biggest banks in the world who will like
text me when
is crazy usernames on twitter it's
it's nuts right but like and that's not
just they're not just young people right
i'm talking about like
people who are in positions of influence
and power at some of these places
uh that they're all about bitcoin they
literally are sitting there watching the
charts
i'm like what are you doing all day at
work they're like i watch bitcoin sharp
and it's just like okay so you got to
remember that
uh there's humans that make up these
organizations and they're just as
excited about certain technologies
uh as as other humans and i think that
that's uh plays a big role into it too
totally awesome is that it thanks guys
thanks for bearing with us i only got
six hours of sleep that's why i'm off my
game today
go somebody won't come out go watch
plana's video on youtube
see ya bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends